Speaker 1: Let's go next to Esteban from Orlando.
Or we could say it.
Esteban.
Speaker 4: Hello, David.
I was actually on your show like two years
ago during COVID, and I asked the question
about Nancy Pelosi and impeachment articles
and whether or not it was a genius move.
I'm not too sure if you remember that.
Speaker 1: You know that particular call?
I don't remember, but I'm so glad that you're
back.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much, David.
So I just wanted to kind of have a minivan,
and I wanted to get your opinion and maybe
shed some light on one of the newest, I guess,
conspiracies that's being spread by these
crazy righties.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Now, sure you do that.
We have a couple issues.
One is we really want questions rather than
just a rant and then please react.
You also have discord notifications blinking
in the background.
So right now, the calls hanging by a thread.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Let me see.
I'm not too sure how I can know.
Speaker 1: Well, let's do this.
What was going to be your question at the
end of the rant?
And maybe I can work backwards into the context.
Speaker 4: Okay.
So what is the solution to responding to to
some of these conspiracies?
And and these conspiracies are like pretty,
pretty crazy.
I mean, people are starting to say that Joe
Biden is apparently is a double now in the
office.
And I just saw this tweet and he posted footage
of Biden, you know, talking and presumably
the differences between what Biden looks like
in this video versus another video.
It's all due to lighting and whatnot.
You know, it just changes in his in his ah,
the way he told his head for example, or I
don't know, whatever, whatever the case may
be, some of these conspiracies regarding this
particular issue are so outlandish.
And this to me is like next.
I have never seen anything this this crazy
before.
Like when it comes to, like, mainstream politics.
So I try to engaging with some of these people.
It was no, look, they just say that I'm creating
fantasies and making up stories and, you know,
not opening my eyes enough to what's really
going on.
And this type of rhetoric is it's not uncommon.
I mean, it happens with tons and tons of other
types of conspiracies and similar situations.
So what would be my guess?
There will be some advice with regards to
actually getting to these sorts of people,
maybe refuting some of these claims of actual
facts because it doesn't seem like actual
facts make any difference.
So is it better to just ignore them?
Speaker 1: It is better to just ignore them.
Yeah.
And I mean, I'm in a disconnect and maybe
you can just listen on the stream just because
the blinking is very, very distracting.
So here's the deal.
Some of these fringe conspiracy theories,
I wouldn't even engage with them.
I mean, Biden's got to Biden's dead and there's
a body double that's up there with like JFK
or JFK jr are still alive and running government
alongside trump.
I wouldn't waste my time on that.
There are conspiracy theories that are that
are really damaging.
Like, for example, people who think the vaccines
give you COVID, for example, or stuff like
that, where it has a public health impact
that Trump won the election, even that has
a serious voting impact.
But the Bidens are dead.
Biden's dead and it's a body double is such
a niche one that I would not even bother engaging
with that.
And the thing is, you can't even really present
facts because it's there's no evidence for
the claim.
So if you want to engage with it, I would
just put the person making the claim in the
position of having to prove it, which obviously
they can't.
But there's no facts because it's a it's an
indivisible claim.
No, it's sort of like if I say there's an
invisible elephant in the room with me, okay,
well, let's put baby powder down on the floor.
So when the elephant moves, it'll disturb
the baby powder.
It's like, no, it's an it's an invisible and
weightless elephant.
Oh, okay.
Well, in that case, let's put food in it,
because eventually the elephant is going to
need to eat and then we'll notice the food.
No, it's an invisible, weightless elephant
that doesn't need to eat.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
So I just would not even engage with that.
Let's take a very quick break and then we'll
get back and take more calls.
So if you're holding on to talk to me and
you want to continue holding on, don't hang
up.
And we'll be right back to the phones.